mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
abcd is a quadrilateral
point o is alongside a d and is the
center of a semicircle that is tangent
to sides a b
b c and c d
if a b is equal to 9
c d is equal to 16 and a 0 is equal to
od
what is the length of a d
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to solve this problem we'll use the
principle of equal tangence to a circle
suppose p is a circle and a is a point
exterior to the circle
if a b and ac are exterior tangents we
will show that a b is equal to ac
to do this construct radii pb and pc
from here we will construct two
congruent right triangles
it will then be easy to show that the
length of a b is equal to the length of
ac
thus a b is equal to ac
now let's solve the problem
suppose e is the point of tangency along
a b
then the radius o e will be
perpendicular to a b
and suppose it has a length equal to r
let f be the point of tangency along c d
the radius o f will be perpendicular to
c d and will have the same length equal
to the radius of the semicircle
since a0 is equal to od
triangle aeo is congruent to triangle
dfo
thus if ae has a length equal to x
df will have a length equal to the same
value of x
we can now set up a plan of attack to
solve the problem
we want to calculate the value of r
squared plus x squared
if we do that we will get the value of
ao squared and we will also get the
value of od squared
then ad is equal to ao plus od
so let's go and calculate the value of r
squared plus x squared it will take many
steps
to get started recall that a b has a
length equal to nine
thus eb will have a length equal to 9
minus x
then recall that cd has a length equal
to 16 so cf will have a length equal to
16 minus x
we will then use the principle of equal
tangence
suppose g is the point of tangency along
b c
then we will have that b e
is equal to b g
so b g is equal to nine minus x
we will also have that c f is equal to c
g
so cg is equal to 16 minus x
from here we will construct og which is
a radius of the semicircle
we will then construct ob
and we will also construct oc
we now have one pair of right triangles
that are congruent
we then have another pair of right
triangles that are congruent and we have
a third pair of right triangles that are
congruent to each other
now let's just focus on the
quadrilateral
and some of the angles
let's suppose that aoe has a value equal
to theta
the corresponding angle in the other
blue triangle will also be equal to
theta
in the two purple triangles let's
suppose each of these angles is equal to
alpha
and then in the two green triangles
let's suppose each of these angles is
equal to beta
since a d is a straight line we will
have two theta plus two alpha plus 2
beta is equal to 180 degrees
if we divide both sides of this equation
by 2
we get theta plus alpha plus beta is
equal to 90 degrees
in other words alpha plus beta
and theta are complementary
so we focus on this right triangle where
one angle is equal to theta
another angle is a right angle
the remaining angle must be equal to
alpha plus beta
we then have r over x is equal to the
tangent of the quantity alpha plus beta
we can use the tangent sum formula to
get the following equation
from here we'll look at this purple
triangle to get the value of tangent of
alpha it'll be equal to 9 minus x all
over r
in the green triangle we can get the
tangent of beta is equal to 16 minus x
all over r
we thus focus on these equations and
we'll simplify them
we'll substitute in for tangent of alpha
and tangent of beta
we then simplify this fraction we'll
multiply the numerator and denominator
by r squared
and then we'll continue to simplify
we simplify the numerator
then we can cancel out the r terms on
both sides of this equation
from here we will cross multiply
then we will continue to simplify
the 25x terms cancel out
and we group the x squared terms so we
get r squared plus x squared is equal to
144
which is equal to 12 squared
we thus have solved for the value of r
squared plus x squared and that's
exactly equal to ao squared and exactly
equal to od squared
thus ao is equal to od is equal to 12
and ad is equal to al plus od which is
equal to 24 and that's our answer
now you might be wondering if you could
solve for the value of r or the value of
x
the answer is no
the reason is this diagram actually
corresponds to a family of different
quadrilaterals as i will show you in the
following animations
while we cannot solve for the value of r
or x
we can see that in all of these
quadrilaterals we have the same constant
distance of a d
and i think that's quite fascinating
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]